giannis gives it up
portis waits takes and
hits at the buzzer excellent poise from
portis and takes it in for two
true holiday they go inside nice knock
away by portis
forbes will save it back off to drew
holliday
down the middle puts on the brakes and
fires
and they're gonna have to figure out a
way to stop middleton
how gets it down low and it's portis
durant almost picked up his fifth foul
or actually picked up his fourth foul
stayed in the game
and almost picked up his fifth as portis
gets to the rim
if he had picked up that foul going out
grin forbes can't hit bobby portis the
rebound the put back out of foul
multiple screening actions print forbes
wide open
three and then it gets people to the
office
member of brooklyn five for 25
in the first period just 11 points
portis goes back door
on a nice feed from connaughton chris
middleton
so giannis to get a brief rest nice pass
quarters hammers it down
really forbes oh it's stolen
portis
back-to-back great energy games by bobby
porter's remember
you won't want to miss be sure to watch
all of the att
5g courtside concerts by
the qr code
here's donald trump
trying to get the fire on quarters but
no foul
forward and quarters ever to go all the
way just didn't beat the shot clock and
capela keeps a live streak by lopez
on the run and stunts
timeout call by nate mcmillan this is
the type of defense
and intensity we saw in game two by the
books and that's your center
coming up with the steal and crazy eyes
with the crazy dunk
bobby portis in the bucks rolling
[Applause]
gets the steal at one end and the dish
to holiday defensively
uh the knockdown
that pass to calinaro off the mark here
comes portis
portis all the way backs at home
[Applause]
middleton lopez set the pick portis
for lopez and he snuffs
[Applause]
with their offense and this man has been
unreal here in this second half from
chris middleton
with the letter
[Music]
trae young coming back healthy
and deandre hunter is back in action
that's a big loss
absolutely no lift in his shots and
here's the putback by
bobby portis he's also in double figures
now as well and he hurt the knee drawing
a charge on it to the
ball in the third quarter in game two
but no structural damage it's just sore
nice feet inside portis with the flush
aggressive playmaker giannis
puts the ball in the deck look at bobby
porters not standing at that three-point
line
the ability to slash behind the defense
that's great option
booker against holliday inside block
from behind
holiday behind the back middleton back
to holiday
inside portis for the slam
and the bucks go up 10. finals for the
bucks
and they've got it done on a defensive
end and off of the great defense
outstanding transition offense the
willingness to turn down a good shot for
a better one giannis appreciating the
stellar job by his teammates i tell you
what
we're midway through the fourth cameron
payne drives layout blocked by
portis rejected out of bounds
payne is shaken up wonder why this crowd
loves bobby porters
exhibit a competitive spirit
and if they reviewed that much like
those out of bounds calls
with their former mvp on the bench
conaton not that time portis the rebound
comes up short rebound taken by portis
foul
shot count it and one bobby portis
in the pick and roll which opened up
portis second shot game he misses the
first one
good pursuit excellent strength
left handed holiday has been sensational
defensively on the outstanding defensive
play by drew holiday so they've easily
given up the easy deuce portis country
and in transition holliday then
finds a trailing bobby port
portis and bobby portis loves himself
some bobby portis
i too had the honor to work with him
unfortunately i also had to work with
mike fratello
[Laughter]
bobby portis nails another right now he
is carrying them
he's got 20 points here in the third and
he's 12 of 13 from the line
payne misses portis right there to
defend
hollande steps back way off an air ball
tucker the rebound
out to portis quarters the floater is
good
bobby potter's electrifying the crowd
[Applause]
holiday double team finds portis horis
hesitates now drives gets inside and
finishes
bobby portis once again